hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
in prudentius's poem the psychomachia
the battle for the soul
after the
combats seem to be over after the battle
seems to be finished let's try one more
time
in prudentius's poem the psychomachia or
the battle for the soul after the
battles in combat seem to be
finished there's a final
sneak attack that is made in the very
heart
of the camp of the virtues and we find
that there's two virtues in particular
that are very very important towards the
end of the work and one of those is the
virtue that is going to be attacked so
we begin with concord concordia an
agreement between people a lack of
disagreement
gives the command to take the victorious
penance and flags back to camp we read
that the army looks really wonderful
they're marching back they're singing
psalms on one side of the line the foot
soldiers the mounted soldiers singing
hymns from the other and this is likened
to the victorious israelites looking
back to the red sea during the exodus
and so with the defeat of vice the
virtues
sing their psalms the victorious army at
least reaches
camp and so it seems at this moment like
everything has been successful they have
defeated all the vices the vices have
left but there's still one vice
left there
on what turns out to be a
suicide
mission
concorde
is struck in the side by a lurking vice
she's uninjured because the fabric of
steel repels the point and the blow does
not reach her flush yet an opening
allows her skin to be scratched discord
the opposite of concord discordia had
slipped among the virtues in the guise
of a
friend she left her torn cloak and her
snakes behind while with olive branches
in her hair she joined in the
celebration but she hid a knife in her
clothes because she wanted to hurt
concord and concord here is talked about
as the
greatest of the virtues so she she fails
but she partly succeeds in that she's
able to
scratch
concord
concord's
comrades turn towards her see blood
dripping through the armor
and then they all want to know what's
going on here and they surround discord
and they say who are you
they they demand of her they tell them
her name her race her nation and her
faith who sent her and the name of the
god she worships in her fear
she cannot lie
what does she say well this is very
interesting
instead of it just being a you know
natural tendency of human nature to be
in disharmony with each other
discord here is identified with
something that has to do with religion
she says i am known as discord and
sometimes men
call me
heresy i see god in various ways now
smaller now greater now in a twofold
manner now single
when i desire he lacks substance and as
a ghost or he is my soul when i decide
to mock him belly all
nothingness is my teacher the world is
my home and then faith the virtue who
first fought at the very beginning will
tolerate no more of such blasphemy in a
single thrust the queen of the virtues
pins with the spear the tongue of
discord and stops her breath the other
virtues tear the body of discord apart
each of the virtues tosses a bit of her
flesh into the breeze or to the dogs or
to her crow to crows pieces of her body
are dropped in the sewers and flushed
out to see to be devoured by monsters
now this is very interesting dreadful
heresy torn limb from limb has perished
it's kind of similar to what happened
with ura wrath or anger where it was
turned against itself the
penalty the death of discord which tears
things apart is to be
herself
torn apart and thrown
asunder so now we have all of the
virtues
safe
and settled behind the protection
they've built in the center of camp the
two sisters faith and concord who had
been identified as you know the greatest
of the virtues the queen of the virtues
stand there on the platform united
united in what they're sworn allegiance
to the lord to jesus
since they share authority they stand
together and from that place they summon
all their followers so we have concord
and faith existing in a relationship of
concord with all the other virtues who
they rule over and govern all of whom
are
in concord
with each other
concord then gives a speech
a very important speech
she says listen you've won the victory
you you uh beat the the vices but the
peace of this nation demands that all
men in field and town live together in
harmony quarrels at home upset the good
common to all
difference from within will weaken us
abroad so if you don't want the vices to
come back and beset you if you want this
victory to be a permanent one
we gotta have concord i'm concord but i
need to see concord with the rest of you
and she goes on and says a will divided
always assures disorder and will place
two at variance within one heart human
beings themselves can be divided against
themselves let love
unite understanding let our one life
exist for one aim
separation is not strength just as
christ can intervene between god and man
joining mortality and divinity so that
the flesh and god spirit are
are kept together
may it be that one spirit will form in
us
and in the body be one action united
let's see
concord and then she goes on and says
virtues that are active virtues that are
doing their jobs will produce only
peace peace is the standard by which the
stars flourish and the earth is always
at rest without peace
nothing is actually pleasing to god so
we have to watch out for wrath we have
to watch out for envy we have to watch
out for pride all of these vices that
we've fought before
so this is a very important
speech
and the assembled virtues you know cry
out in sorrow about the superficial
wound faith then adds some final words
don't cry in sadness this is the hour of
our victory concord has been hurt but
faith has been defended
indeed concord stands by me and laughs
at her wound concord is saved faith
faith is safe there's only one remaining
task my captains the war is over and
yours is solomon's job so what is
solomon's job well solomon is this
biblical figure the son
of david uh one of the
first effective king we could say
over the israelites solomon takes the
kingdom that david had and makes it yet
stronger makes it more prosperous
solomon
asks for one thing from god when and you
know asked what he would like and that
is wisdom to rule over
his people and solomon gets to build
this very important symbol the temple
so solomon builds a physical temple in
israel this is taken by christian
authors like prudencias as a sign of
what we are supposed to do within
ourselves build a temple that will be a
lasting edifice within our own
souls and there's a lot of symbology
here you know we can read through some
of it faith and concord lay out the
building they measure the four sides so
the walls will be square the corner is
true with no unequal side to break at
symmetry there's three gateways on the
set on the east side to the south
there's three gates and the west and the
north there's no building stone brought
to that place only a single gem through
which the passageways are cut
there's 12 gateways
you know they have the 12 names of the
apostolic senate um and you know we
could go on and on with that the symbol
the symbology is less
interesting and important i think for
modern
readers what's really important about
this
is that within the building itself
within the inner portion of it
there is like he says an inner chamber
is built standing on seven pillars cut
from a boulder of ice like crystal
topped by a stone cut to resemble a
shell holding a white pearl what's the
importance of this pearl the pearl of
great price bought by faith after she
sold everything at auction and paid for
it with a thousand talents another
biblical metaphor
here is
wisdom another virtue enshrined and
setting in place all her realm by
framing laws to be the safety
of mankind wisdom is supposed to be
within all human beings and this will
help to
keep away
the vices there's more to the story as
we see
in this final invocation
to christ right to you o christ most
patient of teachers we give thanks the
honor that's your due our hearts have
been followed by sin it was your wish
that we find the dangers in us and
recognize the struggle that our souls
endure so
the battle had to take place within us
we became strong in the ways of virtue
but we're weakened when virtue is
captured and dragged away in bondage so
that we and they are slaves to the most
shameful sins and content to be damned
the virtues by themselves
without christ
are not enough they can be
taken in
they can be
reduced to slaves of vice so it goes on
how many times has sin been defeated we
felt ourselves glow with god's presence
how often then have we cooled and given
in to foul desire there's a tendency
towards
backsliding towards the progress that's
being made morally
not being consolidated and made
something reliable and lasting
you know they go on and say
the war in our bones and man's double
nature is always in the throes of
rebellion for flesh oppresses the spirit
like day while the spirit that was
produced by the breath of god is always
hot in the bleak prison of the heart
rejecting even in its bondage the filth
that is the flesh so we have to conquer
our desires and that is only possible
through the consolidation of the virtues
in
christ within this christian
framework faith and concord being
central to that and wisdom
helping
to rule and this is where the poem ends
with a
final perhaps victory over all of the
vices
you